ce monde n'est pas encore prêt dont on
en viendra à diana mais ce jour là tout
sera différent
[Musique]
citoyen du monde je suis là pour changer
votre vie
tout ce que vous désirez
tout ce dont vous rêvez vous pouvez la
voir
direct a vu un fantôme
diana quand je te regarde c
c'est comme si par un seul jour c'était
cool
je ne veux plus être comme eux qui que
ce soit je veux être une super
prédatrice
tu as toujours tout alors que les gens
comme moi eux n'ont rien eu maintenant
c'est mon tour
va falloir t'y faire
j'ai jamais aimé les règles la réponse
c'est toujours plaisant
vu comment je pilote ils pourront jamais
nous retrouver j'ai oublié de temps
parler de quoi des radars et ce qui vaut
est ce qu'ils vont nous tirer dessus
[Musique]
barbara qu'est ce que tu as fait
je suis pas fana de celui là je sais que
oui je suis prêt à y aller
je pense qu'on peut faire mieux que ça
pantalon parachute
oui tout le monde saute en parachute
maintenant